عاد ثعلوب المحتاج نحن صغار نحن صغار
ولدينا بعض الافكار وكشفنا بذكاء من ناحيه
الثعلب المكه نحن صغار نحن صغار ولدينا
بعض الافكار وكشفنا بذكاء من ناحيه الثعلب
المكار
مره جاء ودق الباب يلبس مثل الجده مره جاء
ودق الباب يلبس مثل الجده ثياب لكن جدهنا
المحبوبه لا تملك تلك الانياب عاد ثعلوب
المحتاج
ايضا جاء بشكل مهرج ويريد اليه ان نخرج
ووحيدا دون اطفال حوله وبسعاده تتفرج
نحن صغار نحن صغار ولدينا بعض الافكار
وكشفنا بذكاء من ناحيه الثعلب المكار نحن
صغار نحن صغار ولدينا بعض الافكار وكشفنا
بذكاء من ناحيه الثعلب المكان
احرجنا دوما ثعلوب اضحكنا بالخارج نطه
ارعبه بابا سنجوب لما امام المنزل ضبطه
ادركنا بالفطنه حياله ياتين ولا يسطر ذيله
ادركنا بالفتنه حيله ياتين ولا يستر ذيلا
وله صوت خشن مرعب لا يحسن اصواتا بدله
مهما قالت يا احباب ثعلوب دوما كذاب
اعطتنا صورا للماكر ملصقه له خلف الباب
ماما قالت يا احباب ثعلوب دوما كذاب
[موسيقى]